this nightcap will be game eight between
these two teams in the first month plus
so
so belt at the plate with talkman at
second base in scoring position
had two hits and five runs batted in in
the first inning of game one
belt it's a high drive to right it
is out of here another first inning home
run for belt and it's two nothing
this one was a line drive giants with a
two-nothing lead
on the belt home run rymel tapia
and with your motion longoria can he
make to play
almost but what a play that was
by longoria just to get to the ball
because that's going to be an easy
double otherwise if it goes down the
line
top of the second inning lead off man on
base
long look in and glance over to first
there goes dubon the pitch swing and a
miss throw to second
and he is toast
elias diaz with another wonderful throw
cuts down dubon trying to steal
we have seen aaliyah show off that big
arm and
aaliyah sprung to his feet that ball
right online a little bit high but
enough time for mcmahon to put the tag
down on that
lead leg coors field the giants are
leading two nothing
top of the third inning floor is and he
drives this one into left field for a
base hit
off single belt is on base again here's
longoria
1-0 pitch this one's ripped into left
field for a base hit
rounding third getting the green light
as flores the throw to the plate the tag
by diaz and he's out
gunned down at home still the giants
lead is at two to nothing
great throw from tapia
he kept that low too so belt couldn't go
to third
i love how deep also that josh fuentes
was
for the cut off okay so as this throws
coming in
josh is way back by the by the mound
so for now the defense saves castellani
a run
and here's austin slater
and mack with a great play there's one
spinning to first great throw by story
a prettier double play you will not see
fourth inning two nothing san francisco
the giants have runners at first and
secondly for ryan castellani so he gives
way to robert stephenson stares at
second wood squares to bunt puts it down
in front of the plate stevenson will
field throw to first
sacrifice successful on a one-two pitch
with mcmahon covering
runners to second and third with two
down now
you don't want your left hand on the
knob of the bat you want to slide it
up so you have better control of the
barrel and you don't want your fingers
exposed either get ready to work against
tockman
the one-two pitch to talkman swing and a
miss
down goes the former rocky as stevenson
works out of it
and leaves runners at second and third
part of the order for the rockies
in the bottom of the fourth now the
tying run comes to the plate
oh baby take a good look you won't see
this one for long
two rows shy of the concourse and we're
all leaving
cj crone absolutely
demolished that baseball like a spinning
cement mixer on the subaru super moments
cj
just hammered it well duggar's going to
face givens whereas longoria crawford
are your base runners
duggar lines one into left field a base
hit
that should score two it does giants
take to lead
three walks in the inning two have
scored steve duggar does a great job
zoning in on his pitch doesn't try to do
too much
feeds the ball out left field off a nice
sinker out over the plate
now here is duvonne owen two
cashing in the opportunities like the
one presented here
pitch strike three called fast pull on
the outer half at the knees
for the second out the catcher cassalli
comes up
one-two pitch to curt casalli
swing and a miss struck him out that'll
end the inning
giants are back in front four to two 4-2
with the giants trying to add on
here in the sixth one away and talkman
will come up
two-in-one pitch swinging and bounced
softly up the first base side
rushing down the line to get it and is a
crone and he reaches out to tag
talkman and the ball flies out of his
glove and goes down the right field line
a little bit before
mcmahon can retrieve it just ran right
through the tag
and uh krone couldn't hang on to it
wilmer flores now with one out and one
on
3-2 pitch swing and there's a drive into
left field hit pretty well
way back there down the line and hurry
up wilmer flores
plants one in the tunnel just to the
right of the foul pole down the left
field line and out of the ballpark with
plenty to spare
and the giants have a six to two lead
he's come up in the bottom of the six
but it's now six to two giants c.j krohn
leads off
here's tyler rogers the submariner
dipping down throwing
struck him out swinging with the rising
slide of the broke
well off the outside corner and that one
did baffle
cj crone
here's a swing and a one hopper to
second fielded by
flores on the edge of the outfield grass
and he throws blackman out at first
the rockies are down by four they need a
big rally
this ball lied to left center field by
treyo
and talkman cuts it off that was well
done
as he holds treyo to a single
top of the order and rymeltopia
got him to chase the slider out of the
strike zone that's strike three
and trevor story you as one of the
rockies six hits
2-0 lying down the left field line
that's a fair ball
headed into the corner it's going to
score two
trejo home hampson home it's a 6-4
game and the rockies will get the tying
run to the plate
here comes charlie blackmon has the
tying run at third
and the winning run at first here we go
three and two
deeply good luck you won't see it for
long
what a comeback
unbelievable charlie
blackman has won it a three-run
walk-off